what if any hasn't people playing with
slime cutting so tapping their nails on
glass and whispering have in common the
hell is that a kind of tinkling
sensation in the back of the head and
down the spine referred to as ASMR every
day millions of people watch videos on
Instagram YouTube and twitch in order to
elicit the stinging response the thing
is we don't know much about why it
happens I reached out to one of the
authors of one of the first studies
about ASMR to learn what we do know
about this tingling sensation my name is
dr. Nick Davis from Manchester
Metropolitan University in the United
Kingdom I'm a psychologist and a
neuroscientist and I study
ASMR or autonomous sensory Meridian
response autonomous meaning happens to
yourself so it's something that you
experience yourself sensory because it's
purely sensory you don't have to do
anything you don't have to make a
movement to make it happen and Meridian
response is a euphemism for orgasm and I
think ASMR has been described as the
sort of brain orgasm or head orgasm and
I think that's where the term comes from
people in the sm what means you'll be
fairly keen to tell you it's not a
sexual phenomenon it's in fact is
associated with close personal attention
that's not sexual is ASMR psychological
is it biological is it cultural like
what are some of the different reasons
that we think that it occurs there are
definitely physiological responses in
people's bodies when they view ASMR so
your heart rate will slow your skin
electrical responses change so something
is happening in your body but that's
presumably triggered by some kind of
psychological state so you associate
eating noodles or watching people wrap
presents with some kind of psychological
state of comfort or calmness we
so those two things are related we don't
know exactly how and I think that's what
we need we as scientists need to explore
why is ASMR so hard to study why did we
not know about it until fairly recently
like my understanding is that we didn't
really know about ASMR before YouTube
happened
I think ASMR is a universal sensation so
I think it's always been around there's
something a bit weird about it it's a
very weird sensation and it's very
difficult thing to describe to another
person and so maybe until there was a
nucleus of ASMR artists who are all
using the same language to describe the
same phenomena then a community of
people talking about the same thing
but before that you know different
people would have a different term to
describe what they were feeling so I
think it's always been there is it
something that you can study
physiologically like could you study it
using like an MRI machine or is there
other can you actually extense it
happening in the brain or is it just
something that you learn by getting
people's you know feedback on a survey
or something like that in principle that
would be a really good thing to do be
great to put people in an MRI scanner
and then give them ASMR and see which
parts of the brain change unfortunately
ASMR sort of requires you to be a bit
relaxed and an MRI scanner for people
who've never been in is an extremely
noisy environment it's a really
unpleasant narrow tube that clanks and
whirs and does all those horrible noises
so just practically it's very difficult
to get people to experience them all
right in that environment so what do
people find comforting about you know
soap cutting or about like slime or
people eating things like what is what
is comforting about that or why does
that trigger it is it like the sound is
it the way that it looks is in both we
think it's probably a bit of everything
it's a multi-sensory experience if we
take the example of mouth sounds so the
sounds of people eating when do you ever
hear somebody's mouth sounds well you
only really hear it when you're very
close to them so if you imagine a young
child being cradled by its mother who's
eating maybe a piece of toast that's the
sort of time when when that child with
it experience another person's mouth
sounds so if we think of mouth sounds as
a trigger
sense of being comforted and warm and
then that sort of makes sense so what
about slime like why do people like to
watch slime videos like what is the
appeal is it like the colors is it like
the sticking sound that it makes when
you touch it yeah I think there's a
couple of things going on with slime one
thing we have found is that when people
watch ASMR videos they like a lot of
detailed action with the fingers so if
you watch somebody doing something
really carefully that's that's quite
triggering for a smile gives you
something to focus on and I think that's
true in these slime videos where you
don't really see anything except
people's hands holding and looping slime
around so what makes people feel ASMR
like what are some of the common things
that trigger the response a lot of
triggers are idiosyncratic meaning they
are unique to each person but there are
a few really universal sorts of triggers
one universal trigger is whispering if
you watch videos on YouTube of people
producing and some are they they tend to
get very close to a microphone and they
whisper so whispering is a really strong
trigger as well similarly any stimulus
that makes you feel sort of warm and
comforted I think that's a very strong
do you think it's used for like to calm
down or for like meditation purposes
I've heard people watching ASMR videos
to go to sleep for example like is that
why people watch these videos like what
is the kind of reasoning behind why it's
so enjoyable and it's such a popular
category one thing we do know from
colleagues who have studied the
physiology of asthma is that it is
associated with the sorts of things that
happen during relaxation so a slowing of
the heart rate and changes in electrical
activity in the skin so certainly
something physiological is happening
during a summer so it's not purely
psychological and and that seems to be
associated with relaxation and getting
people into a more calm state so I don't
think I've ever actually felt the
tingling feeling is it something that
you think and that other scientists
believe everyone feels or is it like
only certain people are able to
this part of their brain I think it is
possible that not everyone feels it but
I suspect that it is universal across
all people I think it's a sensation
that's associated with a sort of warm
pleasurable sensation and I suspect when
you describe that sensation to people
they say oh yeah I get that from a
haircut or I get that from listening to
a boring conversation so when people
talk about ASMR they are all talking
about saying phenomenon and that's very
useful because there are lots of
conditions where people are not always
talking about the same thing so who pain
is an example to two people talking
about pain won't always be talking about
the same thing is there a sense if it
serves like an evolutionary purpose or
why do we have this feeling is MRR is
very much related to comfort and
security and the sort of feelings that
you have as a child that you really get
from a probably a maternal bond all
primates pretty much have a close pair
bond with their parents and quite a lot
of animals across the animal kingdom
also do that so I wonder if ASMR is a
very universal sensation but is created
during parental bonding this one genre I
find really weird and is super popular
is like can I exam or a doctor's visit
and what I find confusing about that is
it's not comforting at all like the idea
of going to the dentist is not very
comforting or soothing or makes me want
to go to sleep at all there's something
there about intimacy you're having
somebody come into your personal space
in a non-sexual way but just in a really
close way and I think that doesn't
happen in very many situations in in our
daily life
these are situations where people will
get very close to you and that's a great
sort of comforting and safe kind of
situation I've seen a lot some are
videos where it's like really bright
colors or things are being lined up in a
very like satisfying organized way or
like all cards all knocking over or
something like that yeah I think there's
something quite powerful about that
sense of completion so something that
suddenly falls into place or something
becomes symmetrical and I think
certainly for some people that is a
trigger for a sense of satisfaction and
and maybe that does link to ASMR I don't
think that triggers a smile in all
people though I think it's it's very
much a very personal thing
it prompts questions and I think that's
what I like about it as a psychologist I
I'm curious about what people think and
as a neuroscientist I want to know what
their brain is up to you so for me it's
a way of exploring some sensations that
have not really been looked at before
Nick thank you so much for taking the
time of chakras I really really
appreciate it
no soul thank you very much
you